pachuca no it's not a wedding it's a way
of life it's a way of being it's a
form of heritage
we import this dress with pride and
we all reach the same goal
a rebellion
[Music]
josé de la rosa
the way to the night fundamentalism
a  pachuca is the result of the
peasant emigrant to the American people
once the peasant emigrant is from
Los Angeles walking down one of the
streets they see a brightly colored
suit and it catches his attention he
buys it and puts it on
he did not know that the suit was from  a black
jazz player from pachucos wave 3 west
point we
discovered use of pauses was
original from facebook discrimination buy
american institute or selection in 21
change to the world today for
us as a way of life of
culture and now they know that we don't know
can discriminate against that type of
people again
[Music]
the pen that what our
roots mean aztlán the hat the people who
wear wide-brimmed hats
ignore cu  I walk people express themselves badly about
you when you see yourself dressed like that on the street they
ignore the words that
say identity
and continue on their way now the shoes
call me in hollywood or pachuca two-
tone shoe is a way of being in
contrast between you and  I two colors
car of pretty girls and january 9 and
they will not get out of california the moment try of
maxwell in his part desmán germán valdés
but they do not paint us the same as
normal apathetic elvis and directs the project that
the swing sentiment against mexico and
powerful of with  tristán are the
pachuca eggs inhabitants from
[Music]
I'm going to tell you one thing that the person
who dresses or who is a girl dances with
power but formidable dance
if she doesn't forget she's lost she's lost
this way of dressing the pachuco this
way of  miscegenation this way of how
we thought it had already died and today it
gives us joy because we have visited
different states of the republic
cities of the republic and we see with
pride that already  people of 8, 9, 10, 15, 18
years already contribute this way of dressing of
the pachucos and
the first time I put on a
pachinko suit was when I was 17 years old
and the day I die I want
all my friends to be the people of the  dance
remember the oven without tears all
dressed as pachucos why not with
mezcal and enjoying life
joy zero tears
[Music]